CATHY DRENNAN: So
I'm Cathy Drennan.
I'm a Professor of
Chemistry and Biology
here at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
I'm also an investigator and
professor with the Howard
Hughes Medical Institute.
And I just wanted to give
a little introduction
to the training video you're
about to watch, this workshop
that we've developed, that is
on the topic of stereotype,
stereotype threat, Why Is
Criticism Unconscious Bias.
And so in this workshop
you're about to see,
this is the workshop that
we run for teacher training
at MIT, both in the
biology department
and in the chemistry department.
So most of the
people in this room
are about to go on an adventure
of teaching for the first time
here at MIT.
So I'm going to talk
about the motivation
for doing this workshop
actually in the workshop.
But let me just tell you
the goals for a minute.
So we want the
people who are going
to be teaching our students
here to know about stereotypes,
know about stereotype threat,
feel comfortable with terms
such as wise criticism,
know some of the data
behind the idea that
stereotype threat can actually
lead to underperformance
by students,
and think about
how do you create
an environment in your classroom
where every student can reach
their full potential.
So that's what this
training is about.
And we hope the students
coming out the other end
are going to be really
excited about their classroom
experience and how they're
going to create this environment
for every student.
So although this
training is really
designed for
teaching assistants,
we found that this material
is broadly applicable.
It can be used to
train faculty members.
It can be used to train mentors
in a research laboratory.
It can be used to become
a better student oneself
or a better mentee oneself.
It's really for everyone.
And it relates to everyone.
So I'm hoping at the end
of watching this video,
that maybe you will
feel comfortable enough
with this material that you
might start these discussions
at your home institution.
So I'm going to make
available to you
both this workshop on
videotape, all of the slides
that you're about
to see, a booklet
with more information
for you to read
and exercises in it,
references in it.
It can be used--
people can read about this
before they do a workshop.
We're hoping to have
this discussion just sort
of spread all over the place.
And I know what some
of you are thinking.
It's like, no way, I cannot
lead this discussion myself.
But you know, that's
what I used to think.
And everyone can talk
about these things.
Sometimes it makes us feel a
little uncomfortable to talk
about things like stereotypes.
But we can talk about them.
We need to talk about them.
And after watching
this video, we
hope that you'll be ready to
start a discussion of your own.
So it's important to do this.
It's an important time to
be having these discussions,
because there are a lot
of problems in the world.
And in addition to
being a professor,
I'm a mom of a 10-year-old.
And I can tell you, I'm really
worried about the planet
that she's going
to be inheriting.
There's global warming.
There's warming of oceans.
There's antibiotic resistance.
We need smart people to be
thinking about these problems.
We need scientists to be
So we need everyone who
wants to be a scientist
to be able to reach their full
potential so that we can tackle
these important
problems moving forward.
And that's what this
training is designed
to do-- start the
discussion so that everyone
can be in an
environment where they
can reach their full potential.
So enjoy watching.